hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we'll be
taking you through the JavaScript full
course
this course is designed in such a way
that it will cover every important
aspect from Basics like what is
Javascript to some advanced level topics
like promises and async await in
JavaScript
by the end of this tutorial you will be
able to implement JavaScript in
different ways we'll start this video
with an introduction to JavaScript and
why one should learn JavaScript and
we'll move on and cover almost
everything related to JavaScript like
arrays Loops objects functions promises
and much more
towards the end we have specific
projects waiting for you guys we'll
create some games and a fully functional
e-commerce website to end this tutorial
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so without any further Ado let's get
started JavaScript was developed in the
year 1995 by a person named Brendan Ike
Brandon was working for Netscape
Communications while he developed
JavaScript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
JavaScript initially it was mocha which
was later changed to livescript and then
it finally became JavaScript the start
of JavaScript wasn't that good as so
many developers who were using Java at
that time
they considered JavaScript as a language
for designers and non-engineers no one
ever knew that this small side scripting
language would have a great future today
more than 90 percent of the websites out
there they are using JavaScript somehow
many of you guys gets confused with Java
and JavaScript let me clear it for you
that both Java and JavaScript they are
different languages they have almost
nothing in common many people say that
JavaScript was named after Java as a
part of a marketing strategy to gain
wider acceptance and recognition in 1995
Java was a buzzword when JavaScript was
developed that's why they renamed
JavaScript after Java let's move on to
what is Javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
Amazon the home page of Amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of JavaScript
in Layman language JavaScript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
likely earlier when JavaScript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
JavaScript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
Android or in iOS but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for Android we have to learn Java
and XML and Swift We have to learn for
iOS but with the help of JavaScript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
Tech giants like Google PayPal Amazon
and YouTube they are using JavaScript
these days the evolution of JavaScript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
Gmail let's suppose so Gmail is a single
page website which looks more like a
desktop software than a website so Gmail
is based on angular.js it is a popular
framework by Google which is free of
cost and it is totally based on
JavaScript now let's go over some of the
features of JavaScript these features
are actually why it is considered that
using JavaScript is advantages over
other languages
so let's start some of these points
JavaScript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python so there are few other
languages like C plus plus and Java they
need a compiler to work but with
JavaScript you don't need a compiler
once you are done with the script it
will interpret and show you the output
in the browser directly next up is
lightweighted Javascript can provide
programming facility to some extent in
JavaScript you don't need to specify any
data type or return type which helps in
making development more quicker that's
why it is known as light weighted
JavaScript is both client-side as well
as server side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
JavaScript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well there is a way to validate the
user's Data before sending it to the web
server and we can do that with the help
of JavaScript the data will be checked
for correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data JavaScript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
JavaScript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider JavaScript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept it does support
other features of object oriented
programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance the last but not the least
feature of JavaScript is case sensitive
so when it comes to keywords identifiers
names and functions JavaScript
differentiates between capital and lower
case letters we have to keep this in
mind while programming
now I will quickly go over some of the
JavaScript applications where JavaScript
is currently being implemented first one
that comes to every person's mind is web
development it was also the main motive
behind developing JavaScript we have
Technologies like angular we have
node.js we can create beautiful web
pages also JavaScript can be used along
with HTML and CSS to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
JavaScript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
JavaScript can take over traditional
Android and iOS app one of the most
important and unique application of
JavaScript is in smart watches the
bangle.js is an open sourced Smartwatch
powered by JavaScript Gordon Williams
the man who is currently working on this
project it is said that this new open
sourced stack built around JavaScript
will replace the onboard firmware soon
the next application of JavaScript is
client-side validation as we discussed
earlier JavaScript is used to validate
the user data whether the user's input
is correct or Not by cross checking it
with the given condition like the user
wants to enter in your website and you
want it to be a user with at the rate
gmail.com in his email ID so you will
give that condition to JavaScript and it
will cross check it with the user's
information like when the user will try
to enter in your website it will check
that if at the rate gmail.com is there
or not in the user's email ID
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
JavaScript is game development
JavaScript can be used to make fully
fledged 2D or 3D games using different
libraries although most JavaScript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
JavaScript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
JavaScript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smoother let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use JavaScript the
first one is the basic knowledge of HTML
and CSS to use JavaScript along with
HTML and CSS you first need to know how
HTML and CSS Works see HTML is used to
create the structure of a web page while
CSS is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with JavaScript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn JavaScript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS it's better to have a web
browser that supports JavaScript like
Google Chrome or Mozilla Firefox or you
can use Safari as well if you are using
a MacBook you will need an operating
system like Windows Linux or Mac
operating system to learn JavaScript a
computer with minimum 512 MB of ram
would be enough for you to start
learning JavaScript but I will recommend
you a computer with 1GB of Ram or 4GB of
RAM for a better experience you can use
any text editor you have notepad which
is free and is already available for
Windows if you don't want to use notepad
you can use other free softwares like
sublime or you can use visual code in
this particular course we will be using
visual code and I'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
JavaScript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
JavaScript let's start this video with
some facts about JavaScript
JavaScript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the Market at that time just
like Java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser JavaScript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of JavaScript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
website's backend JavaScript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
JavaScript means almost every website
out there is using JavaScript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack Overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
Overflow states that JavaScript is the
most popular programming language used
by the Developers let me quickly run you
through the reasons why one should learn
JavaScript and then we'll briefly
elaborate each of these reasons
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks JavaScript is constantly
growing and is a well-paid job
JavaScript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
JavaScript provides wide range of usage
as well let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to design a
website like Gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design UI
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful JavaScript
Frameworks next step is constant truth
one of the main reasons behind one
should learn JavaScript JavaScript is
one of the fastest growing languages and
stands among the top 10 languages used
by the developers with so much increase
in Mobile Market mobile web development
has seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is Possible only with the help of
JavaScript that's why JavaScript is
continuously growing and there is no way
that JavaScript will go down shortly
the developers working in JavaScript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn JavaScript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
JavaScript jobs section
JavaScript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages like Java Python and PHP
JavaScript provides easy entry points to
the world of programming the best thing
about JavaScript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
JavaScript which means you can start
coding right away
JavaScript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
Community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is the more
help you would be likely to get
currently JavaScript has the biggest
stack Overflow Community it has
overtaken Java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
Pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn JavaScript by knowing
JavaScript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
end apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
back end you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with JavaScript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning JavaScript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in USA and in India
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client-side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in India but if you are a full
stack developer in US you can earn up to
hundred thousand dollars per annum which
is a huge amount
front-end developer is the one who deals
with the front end of any website or
application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer but the
amount of money a front-end developer
earns in a year is decent a JavaScript
developer works on the front end and
sometimes backend also a JavaScript
developer may be responsible for the
whole website or just a few aspects or
pages of different websites they earn
quite well when it comes to salary a JS
developer in US earns around 75 000 per
annum which when converted to Indian
rupees sums around 55 lakhs approx which
is a huge amount
designing a UI is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a UI ux designer earns in India is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to Dom
Dom stands for document object model it
is an API for HTML and XML documents
which helps JavaScript to understand
what is their return inside the HTML
document API stands for application
programming interface to understand API
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what API does it works as a
moderator between JavaScript and the
HTML document Dom defines the whole HTML
document in a hierarchical form to make
it understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes
whether it be elements or text or
anything stored in the document the
entire page content can be accessed or
manipulated by JavaScript Dom is not
used with JavaScript only other
languages like python also uses dom dom
was designed to be used independently to
begin with dom there is nothing special
you have to do different browsers have
different implementation of the document
object model every browser uses Dom to
make the web page of the document
accessible by JavaScript let's move on
and see what is document object model
with the help of an example I believe
you guys have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS a prerequisite for this
course let's start things off with a
basic HTML example here we have a code
that consists tags like HTML head body
heading tag Etc we have the HTML tag
here the opening HTML tag and the
closing HTML tag inside the HTML tag we
have the head tag which contains the
documents header part inside the head
tag there is a title tag that contains
the title of the web page then comes the
body tag which contains a heading tag
and two div tags with IDs as div 1 and
div2 a div tag defines a particular
section in the HTML document the ID used
within the div tag it is an attribute
basically that has to be unique within
the document to make the element unique
from other elements next up we have a
paragraph tag with a class attribute
within it CSS and JavaScript uses
classes to select and access specific
elements don't worry guys if you have no
idea about it let us first see the
output of this code before going to the
document object model of this whole
document so guys this is the output of
the previous code we just came through
here we can see the title of the web
page as well as heading after it there
were two different div tags used in the
code here is the output of both the div
text the question here is where are
those ID and class attributes seen in
the output the answer to this question
is there's nothing on this web page that
can show both of them we can use them in
our CSS file or through JavaScript to
specify the containers in which they are
used so we have concluded how a normal
document works and how the browser
interprets the HTML code but how
JavaScript uses this code is a bit
different that's where Dom comes into
play when the actual HTML document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in HTML document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the doll next starting from the HTML
tag and covering all the other tags like
head title body and few more the same
hierarchy as there was in the HTML
document goes with the document object
model also document to object model is
simply the same HTML document with
different representation the reason
behind this different representation is
that it's easy for JavaScript to
interpret this format
JavaScript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects JavaScript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
function for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
The Heading tag with JavaScript you can
also work on the style of this text with
the help of JavaScript as well
JavaScript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the Dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
node the element node consists of all
the tags used in HTML document like the
head tag and the body tag the attribute
node contains the attributes used in
HTML document by now I hope you have
understood the concept of attributes so
JavaScript can access these attributes
as well and the user can work upon them
as per requirements
the text here in the HTML document that
is simply it can also be accessed with
the help of JavaScript it is the value
of that particular element
before installing vs code let's discuss
a few things about what is an IDE
so IDE stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshops makes it easier for us
to edit photos in the same way IDE makes
it easier for a programmer to write code
if you want to write code IDE will help
you write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of Ides present in
the market today we have Sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is a open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
Mac it is available for Linux and
windows as well I think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to Google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from their official website click on
that and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download this
table version from here only or if you
want to download it for you according to
your PC's specifications you can click
on the download button present at the
top right corner of your screen here you
can see that vs code is available for
different platforms it is available for
Windows for Linux and for Mac as well
you can download it from here as well so
if you want to download this for Windows
you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
condition you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it this window will open where
you have to select the location you want
your vs code to locate
any ID you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want but for now I'll be
leaving it as it is and I'll click on
next now this will open and you will
click next from here now it will ask you
some questions like if you want to
create a desktop icon or not select all
of them and click on next now click on
install and it will install vs code for
you sit back and relax it will take time
so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is Explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just search any folder or you can
take any folder of your choice so here
in my PC I'll go to work and I'll
take JavaScript as my folder I'll select
it and see it will open the folder and I
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and I have a few more programs like this
and this you can open any program from
that folder by using this Explorer
option you can open any program present
in that folder so basically what it does
any program you make in Visual Studio
code you will save it in this folder
only so it will be easy for you to open
any program anytime next up we have the
search button to find any keyword or
word present in your code whatever you
write here it will show you where it is
present in your code or in your document
so let's suppose I write here simply
learn C it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press Ctrl F from your
keyboard and write anything here like
it's written simply linear press enter
and it will show you the result the
third option here is for Version Control
if you want to use any Version Control
like you want to use git vs code has
very good integration with Git the next
button here is for debug or it will run
your program once you are done with
writing the code click here and run and
debug just open it with chrome you have
a shortcut for this as well press F5
from your keyboard and it will do the
same the next button here is for
extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
Community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is HTML CSS support just click
on the search button write HTML CSS
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few modes you have to
install JavaScript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way I'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
is
close it create a new file we will name
it as new DOT HTML so it's new DOT HTML
here one thing you have to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with DOT HTML extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write exclamation mark
and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic HTML code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code Studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as I have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with JavaScript enabled in it so
if you are using Google Chrome it's
quite easy to enable JavaScript let me
take you through open Google Chrome go
to settings and just write JavaScript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
JavaScript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so I'm
good to go once you have downloaded the
editor and you are done with the
environment setup and all you can start
writing the program so let's go to es
code we will open a new file here and
save it with the name let's open a new
file and we will save it with name
first.html make sure to save your file
with DOT HTML extension as it will make
it easy for the computer to understand
that this particular file is an HTML
file so in the last video we installed
an extension named live server let me
tell you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic HTML program or just press
the exclamation key and press enter here
we are with the basic HTML program we
have not done anything yet just edit it
a little bit we'll add a heading tag and
inside the heading tag we will write a
heading let's suppose we are writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
but this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see just use Google Chrome
or whatever browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we'll be
using it side by side now let's suppose
we'll change something here let's add a
word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we'll be using it during our whole code
so now we are done with that let's start
with the program so here we are with a
basic HTML code which has only tags in
it it will print a thing if I